going on
you
welcome senator
um i would like to call this meeting a
long-range capital planning and
utilization committee
to order
i would note that representative michael
edgar who is an alternate is
filling in for representative mcconkey
who is
unable to be here
and senator hennessey is filling in for
senator gaida
so
either one
they're both absent um
i would remind the members of the
committee and anybody who comes to
testify that this is being live streamed
so if you want to ask a question or talk
you need to make sure that the
red red button is pushed and you're
talking to the microphone so that it
does go out and it is being recorded
with that
the first order of business is the
acceptance of the minutes of the january
24th 2022 meeting
is there
are there any
additions corrections or
omissions in the minutes
seeing none i would accept the motions
on the minutes
senator d'alessandro moves approval
seconded by representative clutier
any discussion all those in favor
signify by saying aye aye opposed nay
the eyes have it and the minutes of the
last meeting are approved
there
the
there is no old business new business
under rsa 439-c
disposal of highway or turnpike-funded
real estate
lrcp
22-004 from the department of
transportation
authorization to sell
0.19 plus
minus of an acre parcel of state-owned
land within the limited access
right-of-way located on the easterly
side of new hampshire route 16 spaulding
turnpike in the town of dover directly
to eric and elizabeth hagman
in the amount of ten thousand one
hundred dollars which includes the one
thousand one hundred dollar
administrative
fee pursuant to rsa 443
dash a
subject to the conditions as specified
in the request dated january 26 2022
i
welcome the department here to
explain the item
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee my name is steve labonte i'm
the administrator of the bureau of right
away
just as brief background the bureau of
right-of-way is best described as the
real estate group of the department of
transportation
made up of land surveyors
real estate appraisers land agents and
property managers
the subject parcel as uh
sits on the easterly side of route 16.
it was acquired in 1955 by commissioners
return of layout
and at some time in the 60s it looked
like it it basically became part of the
backyard
i was out there last week in fact the
right-of-way line goes right through a
pool
that was probably installed in the 60s
the hagmans discovered this when they
had their property surveyed the surveyor
noticed it they contacted us and they
want to clean up
their boundary lines
i can take any questions
any questions
thank you
thank you steve uh
when we when we purchased this property
what did we pay for it
uh
i'm sorry senator i can't answer that
right now but i certainly will get back
to you by email
and further question
so who
who made the appraisal
that that 10 000 covered
cover the value of the property
that was um that was done
um
with one of our in-house appraisers
and just a little nuance to this
i'm not sure if we
paid anything for it because
this was part of
this was part of a road that was
discontinued and us as the abutters it
may have just reverted to us once the
road was discontinued
it was the state road uh i know that the
road that was discontinued i believe was
a class five highway or a class six
highway but i as i said i will make sure
to get back to you okay thank you thank
you mr tim
any further questions on this item
seeing on what is the pleasure of the
committee
remove approval
senator d'alessandro moves approval
seconded by representative clutier is
there any discussion on the item
see none
all those in favor of the approval of
item 22-004
signify by saying aye aye opposed nay
the eyes have it and the item is
approved
moving on to the next item lrcp
22-05
department of transportation
authorization to grant
an access point through the controlled
access right of way on the easterly side
of new hampshire route 12 in the town of
fitzwilliam directly
to
keith and terry gustafsson in the amount
of six thousand one hundred dollars
which includes a
uh one thousand one hundred dollar
administrative fee pursuant to rsa 440
roman three dash a subject to the
conditions as specified in the request
stated january 31st 2022
and the department is recognized
thank you mr chairman
the access point is a short distance
away from the mass new hampshire
border currently the the owners have
access
basically through the parking lot of a
convenience store
um
and
they're they're seeking to gain direct
access to their property our district
engineer went out took a look at the
traffic counts they don't have concerns
of adding an additional conflict point
in this
in this area
and basically the controlled access was
established in 1959
later in 2005 the bigger parcel was
subdivided
and the access point if granted will be
restricted to just serving the two
single-family residences that are on the
property
thank you questions to the department
on this item
seeing none what is the pleasure of the
committee
mr chairman
representative clutier thank you i move
approval of item 22-005
representative clutier moves approval of
item 005 is her second second seconded
by senator hennessey
is there any discussion on the item
see none all those in favor signify by
saying aye aye
opposed nay the ice have it and the item
is approved
moving on to the next item lrcp 22-08
department of transportation
authorization to sell 1.14 plus or minus
acres of state-owned land on the
westerly side of new hampshire route 32
old homestead highway in the town of
richmond directly to
maurice
zielinski for fifteen thousand one
hundred dollars which includes a 1100
administrator fee subject to the
conditions as specified in the request
dated march 11 2022 and i recognize the
department
thank you mr chairman uh the parcel sits
directly across from the richmond town
hall it was
as it was acquired in
1963 after being leased for 22 years
it was a former gravel and salt storage
area based on its
current condition the department hasn't
used it in quite some time and it is
considered surplus to the department's
operational needs
i can take any questions
i note that in your request you will
solicit the
uh import from the the town and um
the housing finance authority is
required before this goes forward yes
any ques other questions
from
the members of the committee on item 008
saying none what is the pleasure of the
committee
mr chair
i'd like to move to approve
representative mills moves approval of
item 22-008
is there a second
second
senator d'alessandro moves
second on
item zero zero eight is there any
discussion on this item
see none what is the pleasure of the
committee
oh
i got ahead of myself um
all those in favor signify by saying aye
aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and the item is
approved
next item is lrcp
22-09 department of transportation
authorization is disposed of a two plus
or minus acre parcel of state-owned land
located on the northeasterly corner of
new hampshire route 111 and new
hampshire route 28 and the town of
windham
by entering into a listing agreement for
a term of one year with berkshire
hathaway fernandez realty for the
listing price of one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars
allowing negotiations within the
committee's current policy guidelines
and pursuant to rsa 440 roman 3-a assess
an administrative fee of 1100
dollars subject to the conditions as
specified in the request date of march 8
2022.
original approval
uh lrcp 17.019
granted september 19 201
with subsequent approval lrcp
18.044 on november 29 2018 and lrcp
16-034
on november 6 2019.
uh the department is recognized
thank you mr chairman
as you just pointed out this this
property has been
up before the committee in the past to
reduce the price
it um
it was purchased in 2003 for 570
thousand dollars that was a nine acre
parcel the parcel was then bisected by
route 111 in our construction
what we're doing here is trying to
market the northern
two acres the problem with this parcel
and why we haven't been able to move it
is because all but basically a quarter
of an acre is wet
it's all wetlands so there's only about
a quarter of an acre of property that
can be developed
so we're asking to reduce that price i
believe right now it's being marketed at
450 000
we're asking to reduce that to 120 000
based on its development potential
thank you i do have one question
what is the downside to the department
if we elect not to put this back on the
market at this point
good question
honestly i you know it'll just be
another
piece of property we monitor and wait
for a butter to to ask us to purchase it
or somebody comes along and asks us to
do a surplus disposal
any further questions senator delson
thank you mr but if it's wetlands are we
using it for mitigation in any sense
it's not it wasn't purchased from
mitigation and it's currently not being
used it's not we're not getting any
mitigation credit currently from it and
that that's a good point i can talk to
our bureau of environment and see if
there's some mitigation potential there
for the point for other i think that
might be a
a good idea why should we get rid of
something when we can use it when it
does have a
a use and it's also a value in the
ecological situation it has some value i
mean if we sell it they're going to fill
it somebody's going to ask to phil and
they're going to
build on it right i mean isn't that
isn't that what usually happens when we
get rid of property like this
i'm not sure about filling in the
wetlands but they'll develop whatever
they can
um thank you
any further questions
my my major concern is everything like
annually about um we lower the price a
little bit um
so now we're
essentially asking to cut it
well over in half
from what we're currently trying to get
if there is potential for
mitigation or a future sale which
may may work out better for the state
i would not be opposed to turning down
this request but
that is up for the committee to decide
any further questions
um not only am i the department's
representative also the commissioners
designee as a
an advisory member of the committee uh
i'd like to maybe suggest it get tabled
i can investigate senator d'alessandros
um
okay she will accept a motion i'll
accept the motion at this time i would
move the table and i will second that
motion senator d'allesandro moves
with representative clutier seconding
that this item be
tabled until our next
meeting is there any discussion
on the tabling
motion seeing none all those in favor
signify by saying aye
opposed nay the eyes have it and the
item is tabled
um
for
the next is the department of natural
and cultural resources
rsa 440 disposal of real estate
lrcp 22-07
department of natural and cultural
resources requests authorization to sell
a .135 plus or minus acre portion of
land located along the edge of the north
stratford beecher falls rail trail in
west stewartstown to lawrence and
christian rancourt for the value of 3
and collect an administration
administrative fee of one thousand one
hundred dollars pursuant to rsa 440
roman 3-a subject to the conditions as
specified in the request dated march 11
2022.
and i recognize the department
thank you good morning my name is craig
granny i'm the chief of the bureau of
trails at the new hampshire department
of natural and cultural resources
and as stated that the iran courts
approach dncr about acquiring a small
portion of state-owned land this is on
the north stratford beecher falls rail
trail that we we manage
their existing property abuts route 3
and the trails on the back side of their
property
and there previously there was a large
garage that was on the property and
extended into the area
in question that we that we own
there was a small encroachment there and
i my understanding is the garage has
since burned and it's the existing
concrete
pad that's there now so it's a little
over a tenth of an acre that they're
asking for
it doesn't affect our recreation trail
use or management it's separated by
their property by a large drainage ditch
so it's a very narrow piece of land that
abuts
their parcel as well so
again it's just uh requesting
authorization to convey that to them
with an appraisal determined at 3 200
any questions
i do have one
is there an anticipated use of this
piece of property yeah my understanding
is they're looking to redevelop the
property
into some kind of a convenience store at
this location
and again it's right off of our rail
trail and so it'll certainly benefit our
riders
okay
any further questions
from members of the committee
saying none what is the pleasure of the
committee on
item 22-007
some of the items mr chair
senator hennessy moose moves the item
seconded by representative mills
is there any discussion on the motion
see none all those in favor signify by
saying aye
aye
opposed nay and the item
is
approved next from the department of
administrative services
lrcp 22-011
authorization to enter into
a use of premise agreement with the
county of rockingham one night 119 north
road brentwood new hampshire for leasing
053 square feet of office space of
state-owned property located on the
lower
level of the rockingham county
courthouse look located at number 10
route 125 brentwood new hampshire from
may 1st 2022 to april 30th
2025 for an amount not to exceed
nine dollars in eight cents for the
schedule of annual rent and subject to
the conditions as specified in the
request dated march 15 2022
and the department is recognized
good morning thank you mr chair this is
karen rantamacke director of plant and
property and with me today is sarah
lineberry superintendent of court
facilities
good morning chairman and committee
today we're here looking for the
committee to approve the use of premise
agreement at the rockingham county
courthouse
this would allow admin services to lease
18 053 square feet of space at the
courthouse in the lower level to
rockingham county
for the registry of deeds and for the
county attorney's office
and the rental revenue covers our
operating costs throughout the term
thank you questions of the committee
representative excuse me senator
hennessey thank you mr chair i just want
to ask about the the rental rates for
this
we hear a lot in
finance
uh and sometimes in ways and means about
the market rates right now and what the
state has to pay for lease space
is this comparable to lease rates for
that the state is paying when we have to
go out and find extra space
so um that's a very good question um we
do have a formula on that we are to
follow when we determine rates
it's basically we are charged with
recouping our operating costs
and also two percent of the original
construction costs of the courthouse
so those two combined figures make up
what we charge
our tenants in the state-owned buildings
it's different than
you know the
commercial real estate market
any further questions
yeah representative edwards uh thank you
mr chairman i you know i i i have
constituents throughout rockingham
county so
um
i i'd like a little bit more of the back
story here on on what we think is going
to happen over the next three years and
some of this is a probably more
appropriate address to people from
rockingham county but if they're if
they're freeing up space you know what
they're going to do with that space and
and how is it that we came upon as a
state having over 18 000 square feet
that's available did we did we over buy
did things change how did how did we get
here and where are we going sure the
courthouse was constructed in 1996
and as part of the construction process
the space was fit up for the county
so they were determined to be a tenant
of the state at that time of
construction
and so the whole lower level
of the courthouse that the state owns
is fit up
primarily for county space
and the county i believe is going to be
building a new facility for the county
but it will be out several years
thank you mr chair thank you for the
answer
any further questions to the department
on this item
c9 what is the pleasure of the committee
mr chair
i'd like to move uh the approval of
the uh lrcp 2211.
um representative edgar moves item
22-0-1-1
is there a second i'll second that uh
representative mills seconds the item
is there any further discussion on this
item
scene none all those in favor signify by
saying aye
aye opposed nay the ice have it and
the item is approved thank you very much
thank you
um
moving on to rsa 440 disposal of real
estate
and rsa 228-6
disposition of acquired or abandoned
rail properties
the department is here
lrcp 22-10
department of transportation
authorization to sell an ancillary
parcel of railroad property of
approximately point
one acres
on the state owned northern rail road
corridor in the town of enfield to susan
brown for one thousand five hundred
dollars plus a one-time administrative
fee of one thousand one hundred dollars
of which the department is in receipt of
five hundred dollars subject to the
conditions as specified in the request
dated march 8 2022
thank you chairman good morning
committee
my name is lou barker i am with the
bureau of rail and transit at the
department of transportation and
responsible for railroad properties
owned by the state
in new hampshire and vermont actually
but that's a whole different story
interestingly miss brown
listed in the request
had her property surveyed and the survey
determined that her front yard was in
what was formerly the public access and
depot property for the town at the town
of enfield
so she contacted us and i investigated
and
my investigation concurred with her
survey that yeah that parcel is on the
railroad property and uh
it has no future use for uh railroad
service uh road service ended there in
66 i think at the latest
and uh recommended uh that we sell this
property and it's here for your
consideration
thank you questions
i i do have one in in the the paperwork
you submitted with the request
it talks about that there are if this is
only a portion of the and what are we
going to do with the rest of that piece
of property i'm
we are hoping to do the same thing
without making this too long a story uh
the town's ambulance building is
actually located on this parcel so i've
been discussing this with the town
manager um
three town managers now and hopefully we
will be bringing this and a second
parcel which is owned by mrs miss
brown's a butter
uh to your attention later this year
um
when you were doing the appraisal work
on this small did you did you figure out
what the entire parcel was was worth so
that we could get a fair price from the
other of others
uh yes i have a price for uh the next
the butter to her immediate east or
south by timetable
and we were discussing the property with
i said the town manager of enfield and
eventually the selectmen
okay thank you any further questions on
this item
seeing none what is the pleasure of the
committee
i'll move the item mr chair uh
senator hennessy moves item lrcp
22-10
is there a second
i'll second that uh representative clue
to your seconds the motion
um
what is
all those in favor signify by saying aye
aye
the item is approved
we have two informational items
um lrcp-22-006
and lrcp 22-12.
um which are the reports from the new
hampshire council on resources and
development
is there any need or desire of members
to discuss the informational
items see none
the next item of business is our next
meeting
i would like to propose
that we meet on monday may 23rd
it is after
everybody has to sign off on committees
or conference and before we vote on the
committees of conference on the 25th
26th
so that we are not back in here in june
just for
this meeting um is there any objection
from members of the committee
to that date
at 9 30 in the morning uh same time
and if the
lba would make sure that
the agencies know that this will
probably be the last meeting
until the september time frame
i do not intend to to
meet over the summer unless it's a
critical need of the state
for us to do something
and i know that many people will be out
members of the house and senate will be
campaigning or vacationing after
two years of not getting out vacationing
so we will not meet
until september
more than likely after the primary
so if you could just let them know that
is there any further business from
members representative edwards uh thank
you mr chair i i don't know if there's
somebody from the department that could
help address this but um with the recent
vote and finance committee on
the parking garage um
35 million i think i i'm just curious
what the process is for the state
maintaining an inventory of buildings
so that we're anticipating major
costs of either
tearing it down like all those sununu
buildings i'm curious where they are in
the capital budget process and the
parking garage
um and then if there are major
renovations in a few years that we're
expecting on one building or another how
how does
how does this committee interact if at
all
on the
the building side of the capital budget
we do not
the capital budget is developed
by the governor in conjunction with all
the agencies and submitted to
public works committee of the house
initially
we look at that with what the financial
ability of the state to bond is
and then goes to the senate
this committee
does not look at those capital projects
capital budget overview committee does
get reports
on what is there
those reports are online
if you
would care to to look at them
the department of administrative
services also maintains a listing
of all buildings that various agencies
own
and that is updated
it does not talk about
the physical needs of each piece of
property that is what the capital budget
process is for and there's always more
needs than
than money
i'm not sure how that the the parking
garage will be
overseen since uh commissioner arlene
house had some questions about it
he was not
sure if it was just going to be done
totally by the legislature and its uh
facilities
committee or if he was going to or we
were going to ask for help from the
department
that is to be decided and let's get the
the money approved to both the house and
the senate first before we um worry
about who's in charge of
um actually letting the contract go
thank you for the education i appreciate
it
it took me several terms to figure it
all out
any other questions or comments
see none
the committee is adjourned
moved to a journal
i was just going to do it okay
representative
representative mills moves
that uh
the that we adjourn
uh the senator hennessy seconds all
those in favor signify by saying aye aye
aye bosne the eyes have it and the the
meeting is adjourned thank you all very
much uh for those who stay for capital
budget overview committee
that meets in seven minutes thank you
very much
you